you
comedian Dave Chappelle left tens of
millions of dollars on the table when he
walked away from his popular Comedy
Central show a lot of people wondered
what the hell was he thinking that's a
quote fella says he was thinking already
he was thinking a lot of people ask that
question Chappelle says he had a crisis
of conscience in stood up for his
integrity as an artist he explained to
us how stepping out of the spotlight
helped him avoid getting caught in a
trap it's so much bigger than money
though Dave it's so much bigger than
money I know was bigger than money but
you know what I watched one of these
nature shows one time and they were
talking about how a bush man finds water
when it's scarce and they do what's
called a salt trap I didn't know this
apparently baboons love salt okay so
they put a lump of salt in a hole and
they wait for the baboon the baboon
comes stick his hand in the hole grabs
the salt somethings hand bigger and he's
trapped he can't get his hand out if
he's smart all he does is let go of the
salt
babbling doesn't want to let go in salt
then the bush man just comes takes a
baboon throws him the cage and gives him
all the salt he wants and then the bad
one gets thirsty the bush man that's
when I the cage the first place of
baboon runs to his water push man
follows him and they both drink to their
fill and in that analogy I felt like the
baboon but I was smart enough to let go
of the salt isn't that a great analogy
oh he's very very thoughtful and very
very smart